you created a new business presentation  need to present the slides in the next  meeting but how do you do that and let  me share the top two mistakes that I  often see Juniors do first is they're  getting lost in the details they talk  about lots of things but instead of  doing that whenever a new slide comes up  talk about the key message share the key  point that you want to make this is what  you should focus on second mistake is  that people often get lost in the  details as in they really want to  present and talk about every little  thing every piece of information that is  visible on the slide don't read out  every single bullet instead focus on the  two or three key implications that this  applies with slide implies for your  audience follow form of careers